If you need something translated from one
language into another, what resource do you
turn to?
Google Translate, of course!
Since its launch way back in 2006, there have
been few translation services that are as
widely used, by both language learners and
non-language learners alike.
It is so popular, in fact, that in 2018, Google
reported that the service translates approximately
143 billion words every day!
But how good is Google Translate, really?
Is it really the best tool to use if you need
a quick and accurate translation?
Hi, my name is Luca from Luca Lampariello.com
and today I'm going to talk to you about the
strengths and weaknesses of Google Translate
as a language learning tool, as well as all
the ways in which you can use the service
to benefit your learning.
So, what is the purpose of Google Translate
really?
That much is obvious.
Its purpose is to use a process called “machine
learning” to take text that is in one language,
and quickly and reliably translate it into
another language.
The system is not perfect, but in most cases
it delivers free, reasonably-accurate translations
in a pinch, without having to rely on human
translators.
It’s simple to use, too.
All you need to do is type the text in your
“starting” language on the left side,
and then pick your “destination” language
from the drop down list on the right side.
Once you have done that, Google instantaneously
serves up the translated text on the right-side
text box.
Quick and easy!
But how can we, as language learners, get
the most mileage out of Google Translate?
I have a few key strategies, which I will
share with you now.
Never translate single words
This is more of a recommendation than a strategy,
but if you follow it, the quality of the translations
you receive from Google Translate will be
much, much better:
When you use Google Translate, never, ever
use it to translate single words!
Behind the scenes of Google Translate, the
program is really a complex series of machine
learning algorithms and neural networks that
have been trained to translate words and phrases
based on context.
In language learning terms, context refers
to the surrounding “environment” that
a word or phrase finds itself in.
Context is what is used to determine which
meaning of a word is the correct one in a
specific situation, even if the word itself
has multiple meanings.
That’s why, for example, when I say a phrase
like “birds can fly”, you know that the
word “fly” is referring to the verb “to
fly”, rather than the pesky, buzzing insect
known as a “fly”, or even the “fly”
found on a pair of pants.
Machine translators need context to understand
language, just like humans do.
If you type the word “fly” into Google
translate, it will have no idea if you’re
specifically referring to the verb “to fly”,
or any of the other possible meanings.
So it will just pick one for you.
As a result, since you most likely don’t
understand the language that “fly” is
being translated into, there’s a decent
likelihood you’ll end up with an incorrect
translation without even realizing it.
So again, please remember to always use multiple
word phrases or sentences when you input language
into Google Translate.
It’s the only way to ensure even a reasonably
accurate translation.
2.
Create Instant, Bilingual Texts with Audio
Although I just spoke about how you should
always make sure to throw at least one entire
phrase or sentence into Google Translate at
a time, there’s actually nothing stopping
you from translating texts that are much,
much larger.
On its main “text” page, Google Translate
allows you to translate 5,000 characters at
a time.
That’s more than the amount of characters
you would need to transcribe everything I’ve
said in this entire video.
However, if you have an even larger text to
translate, you can turn to Google Translate’s
Documents tab, which allows you to upload
entire text documents to be translated.
Why is it useful for Google Translate to be
able to translate entire documents at a time?
Because this means we can use it to create
bilingual texts with audio, all in a moment’s
notice.
How do you do this?
First you need a text in your target language.
You should ALWAYS start with an authentic
target language text, so that you are not
learning from incorrect or inaccurate language.
When you have your text, you can type, paste,
or upload it to Google Translate, and have
the system translate that text into your mother
tongue.
A few moments later and...voila!
You’ve now got a bilingual version of your
original text, in both your target language
and your native language.
You can then use a resource like this to read
through the original “foreign” version,
using the translated version as a guide when
you get lost, or want to know the definition
of a word.
I’ve been using this process recently in
my Danish learning, and it has been amazingly
helpful:
First, I grab the subtitles from a video on
my favorite Danish YouTube channel, called
WTF er det?
- yes, WTF really stands for what the f***-
Then, I simply copy the text, paste it into
Google Translate and I’ve instantly got
an interesting and enjoyable learning resource.
There is one problem with creating bilingual
texts with Google Translate, though, which
you may have already thought of:
Google Translate’s translations are often
decently accurate, but not accurate enough
to be considered perfect, or at least equal
to what a human translator would give you.
Though this may seem worrisome at first, we
need to remember the reason why we’re using
a machine translator in the first place: to
get a free and quick translation that’s
at the very least comprehensible.
The translation into your native language
does not have to be perfect.
It has to be good enough for you to understand
the text in your target language.
In this regard, I think that Google Translate
does a respectable job, especially compared
to other translators, and even earlier versions
of Google Translate itself.
If you’re still worried about getting as
accurate a translation as possible, there
are a few things you can do:
Translate simple texts
Translate between “close” languages.
The more complicated a text is, the more likely
Google Translate will have a hard time translating
it.
So, as much as you’d like to use the service
to get a quick and free translation of Dostoyevsky’s
The Brothers Karamazov (Бра́тья Карама́зовы),
the end result probably isn’t going to be
very useful to you.
To get as accurate a translation as possible,
you should stick to simple texts, like the
ones normally written for the benefit of beginner
and Intermediate language learners.
Anything more complex (like slang, academic
articles, or literature), and the translations
might look like gibberish.
Translate between close languages
There are certain linguistic features that
can make it easier for Google Translate to
give you a reliable translation between two
languages.
The most useful of these is probably syntax,
which is the set of rules that govern the
order of words in a sentence.
Languages that share the same order of elements
(the order in which grammatical subjects,
objects, and verbs appear, for example) can
be easily translated back and forth.
Languages that are “genetically” related
usually share the same syntax, so if you are
using two languages from the same language
family (or even a larger grouping), your ultimate
translation will be much better.
In this way, it is very easy for Google Translate
to translate reliably from Spanish to Italian,
Italian to English, English to Polish, and
so on.
Even unrelated languages that have the same
word order (like English and Chinese) can
be translated more accurately between each
other.
But what if you’re learning a language like
Japanese, and your native language is English?
You’re not entirely out of luck.
Google Translate’s ability to translate
between syntactically different languages
(English/Japanese, Italian/Korean, etc) has
improved dramatically in recent years, but
in general, the translations still remain
quite flawed, and often confusing.
Fortunately, though, there are a number of
other translation products available that
do a better job at translating between these
specific languages, and many of those have
the same features as Google Translate.
I’ve left a link in the description box
with more information.
Now, the cool thing about Google Translate
is that it does not limit itself to providing
just the mere translation.
It also offers a transliteration of languages
with non latin scripts AND you have a function
to read the text out loud.
Yes, yes, it is still a bit robotic and gives
away to weird results, but it overall provides
good comprehensible input.
In other words, it allows you to transform
a completely foreign and alien text into something
you can read, listen to and understand.
Prepare Yourself for a Target Language Conversation
Another engaging and smart way to use Google
Translate is to use it to prepare speaking
sessions with your tutor or language partner.
When you have scheduled time for a conversation,
be sure to spend at least twenty minutes beforehand
preparing yourself.
You can do this by using Google translate
to research words and phrases that will be
useful in your upcoming conversation.
Let’s assume that you and your tutor or
language partner do not have a conversation
topic chosen in advance.
As a result, you can decide to talk about
any topic under the sun.
I’ve always found that it’s easiest and
most motivating to talk about topics that
we care about.
That motivate and interest us.
That make us tick, so to speak.
So pick a topic that you’re really passionate
about, and then imagine the kinds of things
you can talk about when you bring that up
in conversation.
You don’t have to do this in your target
language just yet—just imagine what a conversation
on your chosen topic could look like.
Then, try to simulate the conversation in
your target language.
You can even play the role of your “partner”
too, if you’d like.
As you do this, you’ll realize that there
are things that you want to say in your target
language, that you don’t actually know how
to say.
No worries!
That’s what we need Google Translate for!
Whenever you find that there’s something
in your simulated conversation that you want
to say, but can’t, simply throw it into
Google Translate, and write down the result.
Then, keep your list of “unknown” phrases
with you, and try to use them when you actually
meet with your speaking partner.
That’s what I do every time I have a conversation
with my Hungarian tutor.
For example, I often love learning about astronomy,
cosmology, and space travel.
So, whenever I learn a new language, this
is a topic I often try to talk about in that
language.
So one day, last year, I was meeting with
my Hungarian tutor, and decided to talk about
the moon landing.
That’s not an easy topic, as you can imagine.
There were all sorts of words and phrases
that I would need to learn, but didn’t yet
know.
So I acted out my conversation alone, and
then turned to Google Translate.
I typed in phrases like:
“The Lunar module finally landed”
“The astronauts were tired”
“Men walked on the moon”
Notice how I don’t put single words, and
insead put phrases or short sentences.
Remember the rule—no single words, ever!
Once I had my translated phrases, I was able
to put them to use effectively when talking
to my Hungarian tutor.
Even though this technique often does often
go according to plan, it’s useful to remember
that conversations are often unpredictable.
Sometimes, your conversation will take an
unforeseen turn, and you’ll realize that
there’s a phrase or two that you need, but
don’t know how to say in your target language.
Again, no need to worry!
As we’ve already mentioned, Google Translate
is super fast, so you can always just open
it up on your computer or phone, and get a
quick translation on the spot.
Since your tutor or language partner is with
you, you can also get immediate feedback on
the correctness of the translated phrase or
sentence!
Now, with that piece of advice, you might
be worried that using Google Translate during
a conversation is like cheating on an academic
exam.
Trust me, it’s nothing of the sort.
If you use Google Translate in this way, you’re
using it to facilitate conversation, rather
than allowing yourself to get stuck in those
awkward moments where you’re desperately
trying to think of a word you need, but it
won’t come.
Seriously.
If you’re worried about this, I recommend
that you actually tell your partner or tutor
upfront that you will be using Google Translate
for quick translation.
There is freedom in truth, and no shame in
using technology to facilitate communication
and help you speak better.
Remember: a conversation (in most cases) is
not a level test, or a performance to be critiqued.
It is a connection that benefits both people
the easier it naturally flows.
So there you have it.
These are just three ways in which you can
use Google Translate.
To wrap it all up:
For language learning, Google Translate is
neither a blessing, nor a curse.
Rather, it is just a tool that when used correctly,
can help you quickly find decent-quality translations
between two languages.
You can use it to create bilingual comprehensible
texts, to prepare conversations and use it
on the fly to help you find words and expressions
you don't know or still can’t use.
All in all, I think Google Translate is a
great tool.
It is free, easy to use and intuitive in most
situations.
It does have its limitations, of course (especially
for certain combinations of languages) but
the overall quality of the translations are
constantly improving.
In any case, I think it is best used by beginner
or low-intermediate learners, and with combinations
of languages that share a similar syntax.
Now, how do you use Google Translate?
Have you always used it in the same way, or
has your use of it changed over time?
Let me know in the comments below
Also, if you enjoyed the video, be sure to
like, subscribe and hit the bell to be notified
whenever I publish another video on this channel.
And as always, thanks for watching!